tires when John McCain one year from
today the election of 86 will be over
you're a candidate for the United States
Senate where you said today what will be
the big issue I think for the people of
Arizona a lot of it has to do with
quality of life a lot of it has to do
with water issues which you is one of
the reasons why you're out here and by
the way I'd like to thank you for being
out here this week it's been very
helpful to us into the people of Arizona
we appreciate your presence I think
quality of life is a very important
issue contrary to popular belief the age
of people in Arizona is not old where we
have a very young population in Arizona
and I think education is another issue
that's very important to them and a
third one I would say which is kind of a
sleeper issue in a way which is more
applicable to the southern part of the
state but is becoming more apparent
throughout the state and throughout the
southwest is our relations with Mexico
we saw what devaluation of the peso does
to our border economy we saw what the
the death of a u.s. drug agent which
caused the border to be closed for a few
days had the effect we have if there's a
very disastrous situation that could
take place in Mexico economically which
there's prospects of we in Arizona in
the Southwest would feel the impact of
that in a very very big way so I think
those are some of the issues I think
that the Arizonans as we proved last
Saturday at the Arizona war memorial
dedication very very patriotic Americans
and are also concerned about national
security national defense what about the
what's going on in Washington right now
we watched the house and the Senate go
back and forth and the political parties
fighting and once again the whole
balanced budget debt ceiling thing was
postponed what the impact is all this
going to add on there like I think the
Congress of the United States both
Republicans and Democrats should be
ashamed of themselves I really do I
think they have disgraced themselves to
a great degree in the eyes of the
American people by not being able to
come up with a reasonable solution in
order to address what is now the number
one issue with the American people and
that's our deficit and if we keep this
up in my opinion we're going to lose
further credibility with the American
people because they're going to lose
faith
if in our ability to to do the job that
they sent us there to do and so I think
many of us particularly those of us not
necessarily young or newer ones are
deeply disappointed in the inability of
the Congress and the Senate to get
together and address this issue and
particularly bad time of coursing is
when the president's about to go to
Geneva to try to negotiate with the
other leader in the world and he leaves
behind a Congress that's in at least
best description disarray on on the
issues that are so crucial to the
American people how long ago were you a
prisoner of war I was released in 1973 I
was shot down and captured in 1967 and
it's been a long time ago and those
memories had not been very fresh in my
mind until our dedication of our Arizona
Memorial last to Saturday where we had
Caspar Weinberger as you know was kind
enough to come in general westmoreland
and brought back a lot of memories said
medication the reason why I ask you is
that are you surprised just thirteen
twelve thirteen years later that what
our relations are with China and the
situation with the Soviet Union does it
give you any problem than you see us
getting friendlier with these countries
no it doesn't and I I think it was a
natural sort of evolution that was going
to happen between ourselves and China as
long as the age-old enmity that exists
between China and the Soviet Union
exists so that wasn't too astonishing I
think all of us would like to see better
relations with the Soviet Union and we
could go into all the reasons for it the
dictators that are old men that are
dying when they're when they assume
positions of power and all that but I
think Americans and Arizonans are very
hopeful and and desirous of this summit
meaning to be at least to some degree
successful if only to the degree to
establish a dialogue between the two
nations have you seen any of the reports
on what mr. gorbachev thinks of this
country have been some recently i think
it was an article in sports and they are
times that he looks at this country is
being greedy and capitalistic and
elitist and caste system and all that
kind of thing what would you think
there's an
chance that the president can maybe he's
right because our possibilities right oh
I think that mr. Gorbachev is probably
accurate in that there are some selfish
people in United States and we're
certainly interested in maintaining the
United States as a strong country
economically and militarily but I'm very
disappointed that most of this has come
out of the meeting had with Schultz and
McFarlane in Moscow I'm very
disappointed that he should take that
line of attack because it makes us very
concerned that maybe he wants to repeat
mr. Khrushchev's performance with
President Eisenhower back many years ago
which setback our relations and didn't
help we can only hope that that cooler
heads in the Kremlin and he does have
good advice he's got experts like
Georgie arbitral and others who are very
knowledgeable about the United States
that know better about what the United
States is about and what our present is
about and to dredge up the old lines
about the military-industrial complex
and those kinds of things are really not
helpful and I have to believe that the
Soviet Union the United States do have
some mutual interests that are in there
both best interests to address including
this the the possibility or
miscalculations which could lead to a
major confrontation or conflict so
despite the news of the past couple
weeks we can remain hopeful at the same
time I think would be a mistake for us
to have these raised expectations which
to be honest with you the media have
contributed to which would lead to some
kind of a deep disappointment if nothing
significant happens I think the best
thing we can expect out of these
meetings is a joint communique some
minor agreements such as cultural
exchanges etc leading to within 15 to 18
months some kind of meaningful arms
control agreement and if that has to
include Star Wars SDI so be it but I
think the president is being correct is
taking correct line and not throwing SDI
out on the table at this time
particularly giving given the rhetoric
that we're getting from the Soviet side
our guest Republican Congressman John
McCain
and now it's candidate for the Senate in
Arizona upon the retirement of Senator
Barry Goldwater next year's election or
34 seats are up in the United States
Senate the phones are open if you live
in Arizona it's two oh two six two eight
two five two five if you live anywhere
else the United States at the two of two
seven eight three two seven two seven
remember our 30-day policy one of the
things in that New York Times piece that
I read this morning about the meetings
between mr. Shelton from mr. Gorbachev
is that the Soviet ambassador the United
States mr. Dobrynin was there and they
say according to their inside sources
that mr. Dobrynin was agreeing with mr.
Gorbachev assessment yeah
and that's particularly disappointing
here's the dean of the ambassador corn
united states he's been more time in the
united states i think 23 years I think
than he's been in the Soviet Union and
yet he's egging on or so the the news
reporter here egging on mr. Gorbachev to
to behave this fashion so that's really
disappointing now maybe mr. Brennan has
his nose at a joint about the fact that
when the Reagan administration came into
office he was given the normal treatment
rather than red-carpet treatment which
he had enjoyed including his own parking
space and all those kind of things in
the past but it certainly reveals a
different side of mr. Deranian than the
jovial back-slapping handshaking guy
that shows up at all the cocktail
parties in the Georgetown circuit so I
was really interested in hearing that I
also had a chance of talking to bud
McFarlane after he came back and Brad
McFarland is a very calm and
even-tempered marine a former former
Marine and bud was disappointed but at
the same time he wasn't at least the
impressions that I got from very brief
conversation wasn't he wasn't depressed
but he was disappointed that they didn't
make more progress I don't think there's
any doubt that mr. Gorbachev has been
studying this situation very hard and
it's hard for me to believe that all
this preparation and folderol and PR
activities that the Soviet Union has
been engaged in including dispatching I
think it's a briefing team well ahead of
time to brief all the foreign
journalists simply to have a
confrontation with Ronald Reagan at
least I hope got a call
from Phoenix go ahead please you're on
the air it's two points Brian
interesting to me that Heisman McCain is
nothing wrong with improving
relationship with common I mean in China
but he has he thinks it's opera for us
to go and kill Nicaraguan because
they're Marxist Leninist my second point
is I was at the Vietnam War Memorial
dedication and I felt the bodies of
those who died were being used twice
with a very political event I wish we
could have honored those people without
having caspar weinberger and william
Westmoreland and representative McCain
calling us said well it was it just for
the next time we go in there we really
go make sure we went on to everything
our caller will you a or all year
Vietnam veteran no I have friends I was
in college during that time and I did
everything I wouldn't have to fight back
or my friends either I did okay
thank you very much for the call thank
you if I could respond to that I think
the overwhelming opinion of 99 percent
of the people who were at that ceremony
was that it was a healing and
reconciliation experience and one which
are many hundreds of our Vietnam
veterans were there they were wearing
parts of the uniforms took great
pleasure in I had literally hundred of
them come up to me after the ceremony
and tell me how wonderful it was that we
had a memorial and that we had the
ceremony and they were pleased that the
Secretary of Defense was there whether
he'd be a Republican or Democrat or
whatever his leanings would be they were
pleased that he was there they were
pleased that their former commander
general william Westmoreland was there
to speak and I don't believe that the
caller shares the view of the
overwhelming majority other people are
there he has a perfect right to his
opinion about the war and why it was
fought and so did the rest of us I would
also point out that governor babbitt and
senator Deacon Seanie also spoke at that
ceremony and I was grateful that God
that they had the opportunity to speak
also and I think their message was the
one that we were trying to convey not
justification the war but I think in the
words that I used
welcome home and that was the important
part of that ceremony
to revisit the Vietnam War as far as
Nicaraguan and China are concerned I
think it's in our interest to have good
relations with all nations I think it's
in our interest also to prevent the
spread of terrorism and subversion
throughout Central America in particular
mr. Duarte has come to Washington
recently and before the Press Club made
his position very clear he believes that
the Nicaraguan government is exporting
subversion and terror into his country
the majority of the Congress the United
States has voted for humanitarian aid to
the Contras I support that position and
I believe the majority the American
people do particularly since mr. Ortega
has just shut down practically all civil
liberties that exist in Nicaragua but
again I respect the the caller's right
to disagree and his opinion soon will be
going to the first flow dedication
ceremony held her there today of the
central Arizona Water Project the rest
of the evening will be spent here in
Phoenix Arizona commemorating this day
for those of us back east it's a new
world out here desert and it's dry and
it's cold which is unusual I think we're
a little chilly for this time of year
but that we're really glad you're here
and you know the state of Arizona is I
was message to you earlier I think
probably has as many c-span viewers as
any stated size and possibly more every
time I've had the pleasure of being on
your show it always generates a lot of
mail both in agreement or disagreement
and I I think you're doing a very
valuable service and I guess there's
indications that maybe the Senate will
decide that they are going to have their
proceedings put on c-span as well at
least the indications we hear I think
the American people deserve to observe
the Senate he proceedings just as much
as the house this is a good state for us
it's second and the entire 50 state
group for penetration of cable
television homes 93 percent of the
people have cable in the state can see
c-span Susan Barry Smith is in this room
and she runs the Arizona cable
television Association and does a great
job and they've been very hospitable to
us as have so many companies that are
located with cable systems in this area
we want to thank them Times Miren United
and Warner and group W and cap cities
and I'm sure I just store I'm sure I
left others
you know another thing about c-span I
think is fascinating is that we have a
few members of Congress that have kind
of become c-span stars you know their
names as well as I do and and when I
travel around and talk to people they
come up and ask me what do you think of
so-and-so I see him on c-span all the
time I guess the only danger about
c-span is if the too many decide they
want stardom where our proceedings in
the house could certainly be lengthened
but I think that unbalanced it certainly
is far better to have have the viewing
Memphis Tennessee next started keep you
ready to go ahead please yes I would
like to play in Arizona I'm for the run
away and I'm glad to see water come in
the majority of people in the United
States I've never been there down around
rodeo and I Pat Ewing and going into
Duggars if they've ever seen a rainfall
how the desert comes alive oh gosh yeah
it's a beautiful place you can head
water out there there's no telling what
they could grow the climates are
changing in the south and in the north
east and I believe it's the place for
the future for growth of different
things would have been able to grow that
we're not gonna be able to grow because
they finance change everyone else
because they have to go to Arizona
there's a lot of people in this country
it has never been
Kara's owner it's a beautiful point it's
a handsome it I'm fine they had watery
in some areas
Wow mm thank you very much for the call
I think you've made your point
Thank You Erin I hate to contradict all
announcement from the Chamber of
Commerce I don't believe we appreciate
it as this kind comments senator
Gutierrez last night was here in bedico
and he said people who come here from
other parts United States always want to
change the desert he said this is a
desert and they said they want a brick
they want lakes in their backyard they
want green on their lawns is there too
much of that thinking yes there is too
much in Phoenix there's not nearly as
much in Tucson and we someday in this
desert in this beautiful valley are
going to have to understand
and we're going to have to appreciate it
in its natural state and there simply is
not enough water even with the central
Arizona Project for everybody to have
lakes and months.i saying that I live at
a place called the lake so I'm sure
that's very hypocritical on my part but
it's not an accident that the water
consumption per capita in Tucson is much
lower than it is up in Phoenix and I
think the longer you stay here the more
you appreciate the desert and the less
you want to change it the time this
evening is over we hope those of you who
have ever heard of the central Arizona
Project will know a little bit more
we've got a lot of talk around that
subject you're going to see some aerial
views that Cruz went out and covered
earlier this week get a chance to get a
better understanding of why water is so
important to this part of the country
next call from Tucson for congressman
John McCain go ahead please
consul McCain I want to thank you for
being a part of our forces in Vietnam
and your sacrifices appeal W and I want
to thank you for your words at the
ceremony on the 9th and the words of
general Westmoreland and the Secretary
of Defense
thank you very much I'll hang on for
your comment Thank You Suzanne how long
or did I just say that I think that
caller really did reflect the
overwhelming majority of people who are
at that memorial and again I think that
the remarks certainly there was talk
about the war because that's what we
were there for the remarks were headed
were directed I think to the future and
to the healing that's taken place
between the American people all over
this country but particularly in Arizona
and the Vietnam veterans and the
appreciation for their service whether
that that world was right or wrong they
still served and they served honorably
and I think that was the thrust of it
and I appreciate that collars remarks I
know you asked us all the time how long
were your prisoner of war five and a
half years maybe how time flies and you
haven't fun any lingering effects from
Anna not a bit not a bit
not one you may remember I went back to
Hanoi with Walter Cronkite's back in
last February for purposes of a
documentary that CBS made and at one
point we went back to prison that I had
been in and I felt certain emotions then
but they weren't about myself
they were about my friends who did not
have the second chance that I had those
didn't return I've had a great second
chance I've been privileged to have a
wonderful family and a wonderful life
and the elected office the country has
rewarded me a thousand times over for
any on discomfort that I might have
experienced for those who did not return
those are the ones that we grieve and
those are the ones we honor
Sacramento you're next go ahead please
yes our recent articles and Time Life
magazine have indicated there are 100
over 100 nuclear warheads on each u.s.
Trident submarine being manufactured if
you remember that then I would you favor
further expenditures of perfect
submarine I believe that the Trident
submarine and don't don't agree with
those numbers but I do believe that the
Trident submarine is a very very
important part of the triad it is in
many respects the strongest leg as far
as ability to not be detected and and
for other reasons which are largely
technical I strongly support a triad but
I also strongly support I think is the
overwhelming majority of Americans do
meaningful arms reductions across the
board if those reductions entail
reductions in the Trident submarine b-1
bombers or cruise missiles or anything
else I'm all for it and I think that's
the goal but we should seek and one of
the reasons why I'm supportive of SDI
among many is because I believe that one
of our best opportunities to bring about
a reduction of offensive nuclear weapons
is through the development of defensive
non-nuclear weapons next call from
Scottsdale here near Phoenix go ahead
please yes I was calling in a reference
to this VAP project all that cats are
currently retain how I can get some
information on some water conservation
sure just if you do me a favor and write
to my to me or even call my office in
Mesa and the number is eight three five
eight nine nine four and will provide
you with so much information that it
will keep you busy for quite some time
so please call our our office in Mesa
which is eight three five eight nine
nine four I think one other thing that
we might promise we just had to
gentleman here from the Arizona
and Phoenix Gazette I have my hand the
central Arizona Project from her special
report from December 83 Pat Murphy still
with assist is still available I mean
out we didn't get reprints of summit I
think that's the best single piece
that's been done on the central Arizona
Project both pro and con which that was
that article I know for someone like me
or knew nothing about this this was a
quick and easy study Ontario California
go ahead please go to Phelps dodge
strike line Arizona I'm wondering if
from where we are these corporations
could production and increase production
in the lines Leone in Latin America is
it all deserve the way that you think in
the future that perhaps the government
can find ways to buy these mind so that
we can keep our is people working carry
a phrase I would like to say yes but I
don't see any reasonable way that the
government can buy minds and take them
over and operate them because I think it
would be almost impossible for us to do
and a great tragedy that's taking place
we've said all these wonderful things
about Arizona and I'm sure you've been
over many times what one of the saddest
parts of our state now is the saddest
aspects of our state is that copper
mines have been shut down the markets
have dried up
we're non-competitive and world prices
due to a whole lot of reasons including
US taxpayers dollars going to places
like Chile and Zaire and others but the
what we are experiencing is our copper
mining town shutting down across the
state of Arizona and our job as
concerned Arizonans is to get those
people trained in other lines of work
and get them employed and that's a
probably one of our biggest challenges
but I don't see a scenario where we
could have the government by the mines
until one thing we need to do across
this country is find more uses for
copper there is a less used for copper
in home building in telephone wires are
now going to fiber optics and others and
we need to find more uses for copper to
create a better and stronger market for
it how much is it going to we're about
out of time how much is going to cost
you run for the Senate
probably around 2 million dollars I
would guess the reason why I say that is
Senator Deacon Cena and governor Babbitt
each spent about two to two and a half
million in 1982 of their races media is
very expensive here and and you have to
be involved in media heavily in order to
in any political campaign that's
statewide someone who hasn't thought
about it why would someone want to leave
at Congress the US House of
Representatives both our Congress and go
to the Senate is it a better job first
of all I think is a Republican we will
be in the minority probably until 1992
unfortunately as much as I would like to
thank otherwise whereas in the Senate we
will either be in the majority or close
to it it's not clear in 86 as you know
second reason in my own case our second
reason is is because you can be
effective as one out of 100 more than
you can add a one on one out of 435 and
third of all in my own case virtually
every Republican in Arizona asked me to
run at major Republican Arizona asked me
to run for that office it's an
opportunity that doesn't come up very
often I've been very fortunate in the
past and and I think the timing was
right to try now that you decided to run
for the Senate what did people in the
house think of the Senate these are his
are a rivalry between you guys already
they if they call me a snob and I
haven't even left yet